I think you presented the SAG Awards I
did and I was curious about that because
I've some people watch things like that
they think Oh wouldn't that be an
amazing time and then I'll realize that
well if you're in the business it might
not be you might not have a good time
did you enjoy doing the SAG Awards was
it fun well yeah I mean I was I was
asked to no no see that he didn't like
it that's all the time we have good
night everybody I wanted to do it I
wanted to be there and support my fellow
actors I thought this was like a great
year but I did have an ulterior motive I
wanted to meet the cast from flee back
oh good show I love that show yeah and
Phoebe Waller bridge I just I really
wanted to meet her and when she won
because I was sitting in a table in the
back I clocked the table that she was at
and so I was like all right so there it
is then after I did my thing then I went
over to their table and just kind of
like hung out like standing behind the
table
Steve you creep I know because she
wasn't there
yes oh wait she went over to her table
she wasn't sitting there she was sitting
I was just sort of patiently waiting for
her to come back and she was not coming
back and I thought and this is getting
embarrassing now people are coming up to
me saying do you know where your table
would you like to go to your table from
another coat yeah yeah so wait a minute
so did you I mean you're hanging around
you're not getting to meet her oh well
Sean Clifford who plays her sister on
the show I did get to meet her who I
love and so I was just thrilled to meet
her and a few of the other cast members
and I said all right I don't get to meet
Phoebe that's fine I'll go back to my
table after like 40 I really I was like
45 minutes of hanging out
and yeah vinegar and then I found out
where she lives kind of fine so I
dressed as a doorman yeah go back to my
table
she tells Phoebe that I was around
looking for her few say oh that's too
bad we didn't get to meet she tells her
agent her agent contacts my manager Lee
Solomon who I was there with right and
we end up being invited to her party
it's nice at the Chateau Marmont so I
was stalking her some more there that's
you know I find that very sweet that I
think people don't understand that we
all have like I'm excited there's so
many people I'm excited to meet and I
would be hanging around just wanting to
meet them and say how much I love their
work and people assume if you work in
the business you know everybody you know
everybody know we don't know we don't I
tried to meet you for many years it was
not allowed